resorts world las vegas opens its doors
on june 24th
this week they announced a partnership
with gemini a cryptocurrency exchange
and custodian
bianca holman explains what this could
mean for the resort corridor
cryptocurrency you probably heard of it
a time or two
especially this weekend as dogecoin took
a dip after elon musk called it a hustle
on snl
unless you're an early adopter having
purchased digital coins you might not
think it's useful but now you'll soon be
able to spend your virtual money
on the strip resorts world las vegas
will be a crypto friendly resort i think
before you have all the resorts doing it
will be a way for them to differentiate
and i think they're just seeing if
people want to do it resorts world isn't
the first property to accept this
innovative technology here in las vegas
at the d for several years now you've
been able to use it for non-gaming
transactions you know any and the gaming
is because the gaming commission has
pretty strict rules and they haven't
approved it yet
california oakland a's fans can buy a
major league baseball ticket with
cryptocurrency
and you can use bitcoin to get keys to a
new tesla or even pay for a doctor's fee
in san francisco
as we have more businesses adopt this
we'll hit that critical mass so more
people will start using it so it'll
become more popular and more businesses
will adopt it
so i think we're on the way to that and
i think we're going to see more people
using this in las vegas
even as popularity grows the
unpredictable swings are keeping some
away
so if the thought of using bitcoin is
unsettling the use of those dollars and
cents in your wallet will not go
anywhere
anytime soon bianca holman 8 news now